okay we're on the Internet Jake Keebler
asked the doc do you think it's possible
for American students to someday be
ranked number one in the world in
science I guess we we are not now not
not at that not at the level of the of
high schools and and and middle schools
and below and one of the problems is by
the way that about 90% of middle school
science teachers don't have any training
in science it's a real problem I mean
the science teachers yeah these are
these are teachers teaching science and
they're uncomfortable with it I remember
my daughter when she was when she was
great too I went into the class and the
teacher you know what do you learned is
like during the day in dark at night the
teacher was was uncomfortable with that
and that is correct yeah no but I
thought at the amazing thing is however
at the upper levels were still the best
the world we're still bringing the best
students in the world here and I think
I've actually said something which was a
little controversial but I think at some
point we have to let the free market
work and say and I don't think science
is more important than English but at
the same time if you want to get science
teachers people with a science training
on the whole can get paid more outside
the teaching profession and you might
have to pay them more to actually bring
them into the teaching profession that's
that's that's a little doesn't help when
if this sequester cuts in something like
a hundred and fifty thousand teachers
will be laid off anyway that's the
predicament we're in that's why central
government discussions about these
issues are so critical because as
professor Krauss says our children are
not being educated to the extent that
they should be and we continue to lay
off teachers
okay fact the Brownback thing is going
to lay off teachers in Kansas it's a
perfect example of that kind of
interesting gadget yeah I know
okay
for Tina Brown is new is print news
obsolete and will the trend away from
printed material eventually extend to
literature
well it's certainly go I think it's all
going on online there I mean you walk
for a plane now everybody's on a screen
right everyone is on a screen ah
I think books are still gonna be around
for a bit but I definitely think
magazines and newspapers all screens
it's good news for trees
good news for trees everybody's
generational I mean I I like to read a
newspaper but I used to like the right
hand right and now I can't hand write
you like an aura more and more I mean
I'm fascinated actually most of the time
people are not actually reading on those
screens either that's the other thing I
mean you know you think they're gonna be
reading they're not that actually
playing their games or doing their apps
and you know and doing all this stuff
it's never it's not really one thing the
newspapers screens one that I think
would help is stop making it that side
it's because the younger generation is
used to that side I think then you in
the newspaper to them is just
preposterous ly unwieldy I agree it's
like a big whale it is okay yeah okay um
regarding the drone attacks why is no
one stated that all US government
employees including the president swear
to defend the country against all
foreign enemy enemies foreign and
domestic
well I think they have that's weird what
does that mean and what cycle it doesn't
mean that you know any random employee
of the Department of the Treasury has an
obligation to grab an ak-47 right and to
movie like Florida yeah you go to
another country that person looks
threatening boom the Obama
administration has been heavily
targeting whistleblowers true an
information activist what can we do to
hold the government accountable for this
harsh crackdown
yeah the Democrats their curfew on Obama
seems to be God what he does would be
awful if it was a Republican
get up there he'd be impeached by now
for Giants EE butch yeah don't you think
I mean no you think well I think that
that there's no doubt that it would I
think that if if if this was a
Republican president the outcry about
drones would be far greater well I mean
III think that's true but it doesn't
necessarily mean that the outcry would
be correct absolutely I also get the
sense that I that Democratic presidents
have to show their hawkish they have to
show right they have the balls to kill
someone and they have to show same thing
with the gun yeah my problem you know
with the Democrats and the guns is that
we don't have a party in this country
that really is against guns we have a
party that loves guns in a fervid sexual
kind of way and a party that says we
love guns too but just a little more
rationally but you know it's not like
the liberal against guns okay um Josh
you recently said that Obama has quote
given up on economic policy what would
you recommend he do to get back on truck
you don't really think he's given up oh
I do I think that the early you don't
think he works on that every day I think
the president has decided that Congress
is so obstinate that he just can't get
any of the important things he would
like to do down on economic policy I
think he thinks he's gonna put his
energies into other areas but I think it
was premature for him to give up I think
that I think the failure of Congress
work with the president is a two-way
street
I don't think the president really likes
interfacing with people in Congress even
in his own party you see Democrats
complaining that the president never
meets with them he doesn't engage
actively enough with Congress and I
think governors like Andrew Cuomo and
Chris Christie show how you can work
with a legislature of the opposite party
that doesn't really like you to get
things done so I think that you know on
the infrastructure stuff we talked about
I think if the president focused the
idea in a little bit of a different way
saying you know we'll spend money on
this but we're also going to take down
regulatory barriers I'm going to work
with Republican governors who would be
happy to have infrastructure money
funneled through their states because
the state's end up doing most of this
direct spending he hasn't done that I
don't I think not and there hasn't been
a public push on that it was a family of
it there was a Rutgers poll that came
out today which talked about how deeply
disappointed Americans are that so
little was said in the inaugural
second address about joblessness that in
fact again the second time around
it's felt that Obama doesn't really care
so much about joblessness and that is
still you know there's the heartache of
the American people is it's not that he
doesn't hear it everybody's not soap is
that what kind of president well that's
what they care when it well in fact you
said you know it's true
you mean you may not want to work with
the other party but the other governors
didn't face a party who the day he was
elected announced you know what we're
gonna disagree with it we're gonna vote
against everything you want because we
don't want you to succeed on that's a
pretty harsh but I think we saw this in
the fight over the fiscal cliff too I
mean the president decided that his top
priority in that fight was getting the
tax increases on high-income Americans
which has various long-term budgetary
benefits but it doesn't do anything to
create jobs this year if he decided
instead that his top priority was
extending the payroll tax cut and
various other short-term stimulus
measures and had given the Republicans
something on town on tax rates I think
he could have gotten a deal that would
have been better for short-term job
growth and I think I think Tina's right
that I think a lot of people are
perceiving that the administration has
decided to prioritize deficit reduction
over job growth and because they decided
there's just nothing significant they
can get done on job growth I think it's
that you know jobs are going either
overseas to immigrants or to robots and
there's nothing either president I mean
either party can do about that
well the infrastructure point that would
create jobs and if universities yes that
would be a great one interest exactly it
would create lots of jobs to spend money
unto you and that no one in all she was
talking about spending money let's be
honest it up until the election the
Republicans the last two years wanted to
keep the economy in the [ __ ] cuz it
was their best issue against Obama which
is not exactly what I would call
patriotic
okay we got to go our times up thank you
very much everybody you were too
Real Time with Bill Maher ask bill and
his guests your questions right after
the show at HBO calm